[Music]
brendan is with us in cleveland ohio hi
brendan how are you
i'm doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i am working on baby step number
two and between my christmas bonus from
work and my two child tax credits and
income taxes coming up i'll have about
16 000
um all at once like within 30 days wow
my question is should i use that to pay
off my car which is my most expensive
debt
because it is sixteen thousand or pay my
two limits i normally do but they also
total six hundred thousand or i'm sorry
sixteen thousand and that would only
save me about half per month so the
total of the two lowest that i could pay
off with that would be about 200 a month
where my car is 490 a month so you have
32 000 in debt you're getting ready to
have 16 000
which do i pay off what is your
household income
um it's hard to say because i get most
of it through travel i work a very
irregular job um
in 2021.
90 000. okay all right and so how fast
are you going to pay off sixteen
thousand dollars left over making ninety
thousand
um well
it i haven't had the other problem the
other
wrench that gets thrown into it is i go
to school on the side of my gi bill pays
as well so when i start school back up
at the beginning of the year i'll have
more income as well so
um it'll be quicker
i will have more income and it'll be a
little either way
either way regardless of your two
options you're gonna have 16 000 land
there with a ninety thousand dollar
income how fast are you going to pay the
sixteen thousand
i mean as soon as it comes in
no honey i mean the second sixteen
thousand
oh um
probably within nine months to a year
yeah how about six months
that would be better okay
so
if you're going to pay it off in six
months
it doesn't matter which one you pay off
first
because it's all going to be gone in six
months
and your your question
seems to indicate that the math is going
to cause you to get out of debt faster
and neither set of math is going to
cause you to get out of debt faster
what's going to get you out of debt is
you're leaning in on the debt you make
90 000 a year and you're gonna have only
sixteen thousand left after all this so
you're gonna do it so having said all
that i'm gonna pay off my car last
i'm gonna work that snowball smallest
largest pay off the first two and then i
want you to pay that car off by june
i want that 450 dollars a month to haunt
you yeah
just let it already touch it let it just
come after you like a neighborhood dog
and drive you crazy
a neighborhood dog
i don't know it's trying to sound tough
i'm not very tough today
man i was trying to flex a little bit
dave's like really
i just most of my neighborhood dogs are
friendly we got rid of the other ones we
live in different neighborhoods we live
in different neighborhoods no i mean
yeah the neighborhood i grew up i
wouldn't put up with that stuff